President Trump will meet today with
Republican House Republicans after they
unveiled the long-awaited details of
that tax plan it would be the first
major tax overhaul in three decades and
two choruses on Capitol Hill with what
we could see in the plan that's a good
morning good morning GOP leaders delayed
the rollout of this plan for one day to
work out some major issues the biggest
of which was how to play for these tax
cuts they had to figure out how to trim
the cost of their plan from five
trillion dollars down to 1.5 trillion
but many of their ideas including limits
on contributions to 401k accounts and to
state and local tax deductions have been
so politically unpopular that they have
run into internal opposition so this
morning we're going to find out what
they decided to do about that what
they've settled on when it comes to how
many tax brackets there will be whether
the highest tax rate of 39.6% will
remain the same and whether the expected
cut to the corporate tax rate will
become permanent president Trump added
another wrinkle to the mix yesterday
surprising Republicans on Twitter by
urging them to tie tax savings to the
repeal of Obama cares individual mandate
right now we are hearing that they will
not be taking that suggestion Gail the
politics of tax reform are tough enough
without throwing the politics of health
care into the mix all right thank you
very much Nancy